what makes for a great acquisition quiz
Cisco were they the most acquisitive
evoke I've been almost 400 acquisitions
it's incredible yeah over whatever 20s
which one which which one are considered
the most successful I think Meraki is
probably the biggest and most successful
one that they bought it I think was a
hundred million and it's now doing over
a billion in revenue that's I think
rough and tough and that was four years
ago in that case it was like strong
channel synergy so so Cisco's a
go-to-market machine and they've got the
world blanketed with their channel and
so you bring in a company that has a
brand new awesome router that's you know
powered by the cloud which is Meraki and
it was like okay that was just went
right through the Cisco Channel all
these integrators and value-added
resellers and that channel that installs
the Cisco equipment zactly now just has
another item on the menu
exactly so I getting well it's like
adding like a beer or a new dessert to a
menu a salute hacked restaurant
yes I'm Arjun I'm occurring revenue so
that one did really well from a from a
performance perspective you know the
thing I always think about when it comes
to acquisitions is the culture that
you're buying and the Joanie I've used
to have this saying like he was asked
when I Ratan if is a saying I read it
once he was asked why doesn't Apple do
more acquisitions and he said well it's
one thing to build a product but it's
way harder to build a team that builds
great products and when you buy a
company you're buying a team and you're
getting what you get what you get from a
cultural perspective so when I would do
acquisitions big or small would really
be thinking about the cultural aspect
it's great at the company I'm in now
it's completely organic we don't we
haven't done acquisitions did you also
one cohesive culture on yeah so did you
have to reset the culture at five nine
or G after it was go it was already good
and that was the that was the I got very
lucky in that sense and and actually was
one of the choosing factors from one of
the deciding factors for me was you know
I don't have to fix a broken culture
here this is a great culture already you
know you look in glass door or any of
the review sites and an amazing culture
people love working there I would I was
hiring executives bringing them in and
there at the end of the day after they
were done they're kind of like I've
never seen something like this this
company culture is weird like this is
not what I was used to and so
I love that about the place I would say
that's one of the biggest struggles with
with acquisitions an example of semantic
banded back in the day did the largest
software acquisition in history which
was Veritas was 10 I think was 10
billion at the time and there were
totally different cultures it was online
back or his backup a backup and Storage
Company which was Veritas and Symantec
which was security and John Thompson who
was the CEO at the time who's now the
chairman of the board of Microsoft you
know and they eventually spun it out by
the way recently but they never
integrated the cultures and the cultures
are so radically different that it just
kind of never really worked and clicks
another spun out hunters later it's
interesting when you think about it what
what are the cultures that are
attractive for acquisition what would
you say the characteristics of those are
I mean obviously dysfunctional culture
is dysfunctional culture so you don't
want that yeah you don't want too
aggressive of a culture coming into a
exactly it's more about getting the
match I mean you know you could look at
Silicon Valley companies and like some
places are very sharp elbowed and so if
you're a sharp elbowed culture you're
probably gonna fit in well they're if
you're not you're gonna get pushed
around you're never gonna get anything
done so so it's about sort of
understanding your own company and what
you're buying and what will these people
actually just like working here oh it
was the other way too yeah you're right
I'm just thinking about how Twitter just
had like a really promising M&A start
and then it turned into a disaster they
bought vine they weren't periscope
that's right and they've had bought
TweetDeck and one or two other really
like cool company they might have bought
nip or did they buy the other one data
sift I can't remember but ever they
bought like all these great companies
and then Twitter had no culture or a
weird quirky culture and vine got shut
down periscope seems to have been the
slowest iteration did it they didn't
kill it it's almost like they shackled
it they're just like yeah you can fly
periscope but we're just like only to a
thousand feet yeah it's almost like you
I think periscope would be 10x larger
now if it was in part of Twitter
well what Facebook live didn't that
really well I just think also Facebook
knows how to do these integrations where
they're just like if we bought you we're
gonna send you to an it was like pixel
for pixel copy
a periscope of course ya know that's
what their specialty is Excel to us or
die yeah what we're gonna try to kill
you but if you think about what they do
with Instagram and whatsapp it was like
let's just take all the friction out of
this and get everybody who's a has
friends on Facebook to find their
friends easier on Instagram own others
Instagram TV right is that what it is
the live brought a G TV I guess their
competitor - tick tock tick tock
competitor - so IG TV might be a YouTube
competitor they wanted to get YouTube
stars but the the fatal flaw of Facebook
is their greed and that circle the Wagen
mentality which is they don't take
criticism mmm they don't reflect
inwardly like in the way they should and
they don't share revenue because they're
so soft Center can you imagine if they
took a Google YouTube approach they're
like we'll give a 30% where 45% YouTube
gives 55% of the revenue to creators
Apple gives 70% so they on on a podcast
perhaps I would say what about on
podcasts they don't have as a model were
don't have it yet cuz you're on there
right we a we're on there for free
I do think YouTube now has a patreon
competitor you can subscribe it yeah but
usually was one of the great
acquisitions of all time for sure the
best cited that I would say Android
LinkedIn
maybe LinkedIn sup there but too soon to
tell how if it's gonna 10x from here
yeah but if you just looked at any
market yeah YouTube was at one point six
billion dollars independently what do
you think YouTube would be worth with
it's gotta have thirty billion in
revenue and what do you think it'd be
worth I don't know six I would what are
they growing you know what are they
growing give an idea
I gotta think so five to 10 X multiple
no it's got to be a two hundred billion
dollar yeah it's big yeah 150 to 250
billion smart a great acquisition
Instagram was cited as a great
acquisition would be we're now 200
billion now so that's a 200 X I would
say both of those are 100 200 X what's
consistent in both of those is they left
them alone
correct until they didn't yeah and
actually YouTube is still left alone
Instagram wasn't most acquisitions are
not done like that right they're done
with the idea of oh you've got to
justify it with synergies cost synergies
revenue synergies and you know if you
don't in its like there's
enough cases where if you don't
integrate it it causes problems so I
don't know what the right answer is to
be honest yeah it's a tough one
yeah it does seem I like building stuff
I don't like like I don't like buying
stuff so if I could build it I'll build
it
yeah that's apples position and the one
thing you missed with that afore they
didn't buy Netflix right they missed out
on that one
was he saying this by name I thought
Netflix Choice Trotec read Ben Thompson
no I wasn't saying they should have
bought Netflix and Tesla when they were
10 billion dollar companies